fallu vraiment qu'on attende d'avoir une
opportunité qui se présente à nous parce
que dans l'état actuel du marché on
voyait pas commencer cette opportunité
elle s'est présentée en décembre dernier
Florence Navia est devenu propriétaire à
Montréal contre toute attente elle et
les autres locataires de son immeuble
ont décidé de se mettre ensemble pour
acheter le triplex qu'ils habitent dans
la petite patrie on a toujours une
équipe une épée d'amoclès au-dessus de
la tête en tant que locataire afin qu'on
était comme tant qu'à ça on va l'acheter
mais on paye plus cher de frais
d'intérêt que on payait de loyer la
hausse des taux hypothécaires
l'inflation et le prix des maisons très
élevées ont finalement eu raison de la
flambée immobilière connue pendant la
pandémie on sent qu'on approche un
marché qui va être plus équilibre
c'était atroce pour les acquéreurs
depuis deux ans et puis on retourne à la
réalité entre décembre 2021 et 2022 les
prix médias ont reculé à Toronto de 4,6%
de 3,5% avant couvert de
à Halifax et de 2,7% à Ottawa les
marchés de Montréal et de calgaret ont
pour leur part connu des hausses c'était
les marchés qui avaient cru aussi plus
rapidement que sur de Montréal dans la
dans l'explosion du marché donc le
retour à la réalité sont venus vont être
un peu plus
présent dans ces marchés là un retour
qui n'effacera pas
toute
pandémie Lepage prévoit encore une
légère baisse des prix soit 1%
globalement
ralentir mais on ne s'attend pas de non
plus à ce que les prix dégringolent de
façon importante parce que des facteurs
qui supportent le marché des facteurs
comme l'immigration un niveau d'emploi
élevé et la rareté des propriétés mises
en vente les inventaires sont encoreides
à supporter le marché au grand Damme des
acheteurs chez les acheteurs des
hommages
tu peux prendre ton temps les maisons
par pu en feu mais l'inventaire est pas
très gros ça fait vraiment longtemps que
tu as fait surtout pour les quartiers
sans trop comme ceux qui intéressent
Florence on est vraiment on est vraiment
content mais c'est un coup de chance là
ici Jacques Audric Charbonneau
Radio-Canada Montréal